new contest okay we i would love for  people to do  a new channel intro this would be like a  one and a half to three second video  intro  which will be the intro animated on the  new pacman live channel  as many of you know we launched this  channel last week we're working on our  first 2  000 uh subscribers you can find it at  davidpakman.compacmanlive  but here's an opportunity i would love  people to make these these gotta be  quick little intros that we drop in at  the beginning  for pacman live and anything is on the  table  the more creative the better a one and a  half to three seconds  send them to info davidpakman.com we'll  do a contest  the audience will vote on an upcoming  stream for  the intro video for all of our  new channel clips all right very  exciting stuff